left-wing commentator keith olbermann
getting a lot of heat for mocking
republican senator mitt romney's large
family romney tweeted this christmas day
photo and a bible verse olbermann
responded with somebody gift these
people some vasectomies well big
reaction to that on social media one
user calling him a quote lonely
childless boomer another tweeting keith
olbermann has no children just an empty
penthouse near central park where he
yells at people about vaccines all day
like the scrooge
jimmy fayla host of fox across america
on fox news radio joining us now jimmy
good of you to be with us um
you know is this where we are attacking
someone for having a large family and
offering a bible verse i mean if it were
a democratic senator posting a family
picture would we see the same vitriol or
would we see some adoration well to be
clear
okay this is not where we are this is
where keith olbermann is he's a really
sad guy okay keith olbermann could never
hate mitt romney half as much as he
hates himself and that's why you'll
notice as disgusting as the comment is a
lot of the bile that comes back at keith
olbermann isn't nearly as harsh because
we realize he's really a sad guy where
he's operating from a place of emotion
that's denying him the self-awareness
that would otherwise tell him he looks
crazy for tweeting something like this
but this is what twitter is you know
it's a fight club for people who don't
want to get hit it incentivizes the
harshest takes imaginable and you're
essentially just sitting there road
raging all day with someone who's not
even on the same highway as you and that
is keith olbermann right now
yeah you know keith olbermann and the
democrats they really loved mitt romney
when he was opposing president trump and
voting in favor of the impeachment right
but i guess that didn't last long no
that didn't last long at all and i do
want to say this though too anita okay a
lot of people who rightfully chastised
keith olbermann also you know use the
famous quote that every child is a gift
okay and i will say this as a parent
every child is a gift but there are some
instances where we wish we held on to
that gift receipt if we're being honest
but the whole for the whole keith
olbermann thing at this point though is
we know this he is one of the most
patently unlikable human beings in this
business which is a pretty high bar and
at this point when he lashes out okay no
one's taking it seriously so much as we
almost get a kick out of how ridiculous
he sounds he's like if you've ever
gotten on the subway where there's a guy
just yelling insults into the night sky
there comes a point after the fourth or
fifth stop where you're like do me do me
you know and that's where we are with
keith olbermann yeah
well social media users in addition to
mocking him also
mercilessly mocking msnbc's nicole
wallace for saying this monday watch how
difficult this is for this
administration i mean i'm a i'm a fouchy
groupie i'm a thrice vaccinated mask
adherent i buy k 95 mass buy the you
know caseload they're in every pocket i
wear them everywhere except when i sit
down
okay twitter users calling it incredibly
embarrassing and humiliating and
shamelessly neurotic meantime a new
forbes estimate shows that dr fauci is
set to rake in the highest ever federal
government retirement package in u.s
history with his annual payment
exceeding 350 000
jimmy is this a good look for nicole
wallace i mean is this her role as an
anchor to call herself a fouchy groupie
no it's embarrassing i mean in terms of
journalistic integrity we're living in
the death of shame for someone to openly
declare that the only thing i will
defend her on is this every single one
of us has agreed with dr fauci at some
point because he's taken every single
position on every social distancing
issue in the country first there was no
mask that it was some mask then it was
too masked then it was i can't believe
it's not masks it's like when you hear
that faux is getting a 350 000 pension
that actually breaks down mathematically
to a dollar for every time he was wrong
about covet
all right and what about what she said
about stocking up on n95 masks i mean is
she projecting a sense of fear by saying
she's doing that unintentionally what
she's trying to project to her viewers
is a sense of moral and intellectual
superiority because that's what msnbc
has become people tune in to be told
that they know better and they're
smarter than those dumb right wingers
taking horse dewormer meanwhile back at
the ranch no one was actually doing that
obviously there is a human use for ivor
mikton but they're not there for the
facts they're not there for an honest
conversation they are there for
confirmation bias hey we know better
even when they don't
all right let's switch over to this uh
amazon saying it's reprogrammed alexa
after a mother's story about a major
malfunction went viral the mom posted
that her 10 year old asked alexa to come
up with a physical fitness challenge for
her the device told her to plug a phone
charger into an outlet about halfway
then touch a penny to the exposed prongs
it's a tick-tock challenge that's been
circulating online super dangerous to
say the least uh jimmy what do you make
of this this just seems like all kinds
of wrong oh it's not good i mean if
people haven't figured it out by now
alexa is not your friend okay and what
alexa probably deduced from this
challenge is the kid didn't know about
this challenge which has been all over
tik tok for the better part of like two
years so alexa is basically just
scrolling the internet for challenges
giving them to your kid and alexa
probably took away the fact that oh if
the kid doesn't know this challenge it's
probably not on tick tock ergo alexa
just stole another piece of information
but this is the problem okay with you
know being so reliant on digital devices
for entertainment and sustenance okay i
grew up poor and one of the perks of
growing up poor is we didn't have an
alexa to spy on us the only assistant we
had was a magic eight ball do you
remember the magic eight ball anita oh
yeah yeah my daughter got one for
christmas i love you it's great it's
great you shake it up and then it gives
you like a nonsensical answer it's like
the joe biden of toys basically um but
the magic 8-ball will never get you
killed or put you in harm's way so i am
pro 8-ball anti-alexa no electricity
involved with the 8-ball no plugging in
anything thank you all right jimmy fella
thank you so much amazon did put out an
apology so we've got to add that in
there there you go